pouvez-vous trouver la magnifique
combinaison de math en trois coups dans
cette position avec les Blancs notre
rois est sur le point de se faire mater
puisque toutes les pièces noires sont
braquer sur lui on a donc la main il ne
faut surtout pas la lâcher je vous
laisse mettre pause une seconde si vous
voulez chercher par vous-même sinon
voici la solution tout commence par un
très joli sacrifice de tour tour prend
H6 échec si le pion la capture alors la
suite est plutôt élémentaire dame prème
cet échec le roi recule dans le coin et
on vient conclure par un classique
baiser de la mort sauf que dans la parti
les Noirs ont pensé être plus malin en
se cachant derrière leur boucliers de
pion mais ils ne sont pas sortis de
l'auberge puisqu'un improbable sacrifice
de dame les attend au tournant dame F8
échec si le roi capture la dame alors la
tour vient délivrer un mat du couloir le
cavalier empêche tout de suite de la 8e
rangée et si c'est la tour qui vient
prendre ce cadeau empoisonné alors
cavalier E7 vient clore les débats en
beauté